when i was young they didn't have as
many costumes a ghost was a popular deal
especially in our neighborhood you had
to get a spare sheet
you know i'm saying i remember having i
remember asking for a sheet for uh my
birthday just to save that bastard so i
could ghost out
you know
and some people you know a lot of kids
you know if you had a sheet a lot of
times you didn't really
you know some people called it more of a
bastard drapery
because you didn't usually have a daddy
or something if he was just out there in
a sheet
i remember one kid would put a sheet on
and put like a little rope around his
neck kind of and he [__] forgot to
cut the high holes into it
hell yeah dude ran outside and got
attacked by a bunch of [__] stray
dogs
so you got a
i mean halloween you got to think you
know you have to
i mean cut some face holes and and
stuff but i remember getting in the mask
remember you would put the tight mask on
it'd be so hard to breathe you'd be like
trapped in there and that tight ass
thing pressed into the back of your head
that little
and if you have one of them cheap ones
bro
especially from the
if you got something from like the
pharmacy or whatever
your dad got you that little outfit
i remember my dad one time got up me and
my brother he accidentally got us both
uh
um
[Music]
raggedy ann instead of andy
and so we were both out there like just
a couple of straight up sugar [__]
man
looking for candy going door to door
hey little lady people saying
i'm like
oh my god i'm a guy
i'm i'm i'm handy but i'm just
i got the wrong you know uh pseudo i got
my sister's dress on
that was the shittiest man
being locked in that damn little [__]
face [__] prison that k dude that
little plastic mask that [__] cuts into
your head
you try to stick your tongue out the
little breathing hole in there people
dying
dude they yeah you put that thing that
mask on
something you can even breathe sometimes
some people die some guy you know he put
it on
he died like damn bro where's leonard
you know
and he's at the funeral and they got on
the
death certificate
raggedy andy on there frankenstein don't
even [__] look for his real identity
dude when i was young a ghost was like
one of the top costumes
some dude would be a ghost
i remember one guy that's got a little
carlton and he didn't have uh
i don't know he didn't he couldn't walk
that good or he didn't want to honestly
bro he was lazy
so he didn't
you know we'd all be walking somewhere
and he would kind of just kind of give
up
and just stand you know
he'd prefer to stand or lay down
or sometime my friend shep this big guy
he would carry him and when i was young
they had rare you know limited costumes
very limited
and uh carlton one time i remember this
dude was a transmission that's what he
was and he put some type of metal or
something on him and poured uh motor oil
all over himself
and we were like dude what the [__] man
but
but he was beautiful beautiful kid had
real beautiful cheeks on him you know
sometimes on a child
it's almost like the lord just [__]
botoxed him
with uh
you know just put like a just a
some warming
just a little bit of lava or something
in their cheeks and carlton had that he
had beautiful ass cheeks too
and i wish he wouldn't have been so lazy
because more people would have seen his
cheeks but
when you're that lazy you don't run
across as many people as
you should
because you're not out making the rounds
of the world
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one